Apple has recently released their
brand-new 20/20 MacBook Air so we've now
got apples complete lineup of mac books
starting with the air for $1000 the base
13-inch pro for $1300 the higher-end
13-inch Pro for $1,800 and the 16 inch
MacBook Pro for $2,400 and to make it
even better
each of these MacBook Pros is currently
on sale on Amazon and we'll have links
of them down below in the description
now let's get start with comparing
literally everything we can between all
of these Mac books starting with
portability in terms of weight the new
20/20 air is now 2.8 pounds still a bit
lighter than the 13-inch MacBook Pro and
much lighter than the 16 inch from above
the air is basically just as large as
the 13-inch pro so portability should be
pretty similar and the 16 inch pro is of
course much larger than the rest the
design of the air hasn't changed since
last year so it still has a wedge shape
compared to a more flat slate shape on
the MacBook Pros each of these Mac books
has a high quality retina resolution
display but the airs display isn't as
nice it's quite a bit dimmer than the
pros that each have an incredible 500
nits of brightness and it's definitely
not as color accurate since every
MacBook Pro has P 3 wide color gamut
which has about 25% more colors than
100% srgb which is a must-have for photo
editors as far as display sharpness they
all have around the same Retina quality
227 pixels per inch and every macbook in
the lineup comes with true toe
technology which adjusts the white
balance of the display to match the
environment around you the 16 inch pro
has the biggest benefit of having
smaller bezels compared to the rest of
the Mac books so it looks quite a bit
nicer speaker quality and volume is a
huge deal for some people especially for
me and we've known that the 16 inch
MacBook Pro has by far the best speakers
out of the lineup one interesting point
is that the speakers on the MacBook Air
are actually slightly worse than the
ones on the 2019 model but they're still
better than most Windows laptops
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
now onto the keyboards the 16-inch Pro
and the new 2020 MacBook Air pack
Apple's latest magic keyboard compared
to the butterfly keyboard on the 13-inch
MacBook Pro models there is seriously a
light and a difference between the two
you get so much more key travel and it's
a much better typing experience on the
new magic keyboard there are rumors that
the 13-inch Pro could be coming this
summer with the new keyboard but not
everyone can wait that long to buy apart
from that the MacBook Airs keyboard
slopes downward towards the front edge
so it's actually a bit more comfortable
to type on compared to the pros every
single MacBook in the lineup comes with
the touch ID sensor built into the power
button which makes it really convenient
to log in use Apple pay online and
install apps off the web without having
to enter your password however every
macbook pro comes with the touch bar an
OLED display that replaces the top row
of keys and is fully customizable but
not that many people like it because
it's more difficult to do things like
adjust display brightness and volume the
benefit of the 16 inch pro is that it
actually gets a physical Escape key so
it's much more convenient for
programmers or other people who use that
key a lot thankfully the MacBook Air
still has physical keys so that's a
great option as well since it now comes
with a quad-core processor now let's
talk about the port's every port on
every MacBook supports Thunderbolt 3 but
both the 13-inch air in the lower-end
MacBook Pro come with only two of these
ports compared to four on the more
expensive pros if you're a basic user
that doesn't connect to external
displays or connect external devices
very often you'll probably be fine with
one of the two port models and you also
have the choice of buying a Thunderbolt
3 hub just in case you do need more
ports now if you love large trackpads
the 16 inch pro has the biggest one of
them all followed by the 13 inch pro and
then the air that has a slightly smaller
trackpad for battery life the 2020
MacBook Air actually got rated down to
11 hours instead of last year's 12 which
now matches the battery life of the 16
inch pro and beats the 10 hours on the
13-inch pro models getting into
performance the 20/20 MacBook Air now
has a $100 quad-core option which we
absolutely recommend
for everyone interested in the air so
we'll be using the $1,100 air model for
our testing the 13-inch pros get even
faster quad-core CPUs and the 16 inch
pro gets a 6 core that can actually be
upgraded to an 8 core if you're willing
to spend another $300 first willsez
single core performance in Geekbench 5
for tasks that use just one core
surprisingly the new 20/20 air has the
highest single core score even higher
than on the 16 inch pro this is probably
because it's the first MacBook with an
Intel 10th generation processor so that
shows it's great for simple tasks
looking at multi-core performance we can
see that the MacBook Air is finally
catching up to the 13-inch MacBook Pro
with the pro still having a 22% higher
score and the 16 inch pro gives you a
big jump in performance as well we
decided to look at performance per
dollar using the full retail price of
each MacBook and the new MacBook Air is
now right behind the pro with a decent
amount of raw power for the cache one
thing you won't find on the spec sheet
is that the 20/20 MacBook Air has only
one fan just like on the $1300 MacBook
Pro however the one on the air isn't
actually connected to the CPUs heatsink
so it's not very effective at
dissipating heat the more expensive
MacBook Pros have duel fans so they
should perform better for longer
workloads to test this we ran Cinebench
R 20 a more realistic benchmark which is
long enough to heat the systems up and
see how well the cooling systems work
surprisingly the single fan on the
$1,300 pro didn't really limit
performance like we thought it would but
the 20/20 MacBook Air performed way
worse than expected because of the fan
not being connected to the heatsink and
the 16 inch MacBook Pro of course
performed by far the best in terms of
performance for the cache in long term
heavy workloads like instead of inch are
20 the air is actually now the loser
because it can't keep itself cool we
then tested graphics performance using
Geekbench fives mettle test and the 16
inch MacBook Pro destroyed the rest of
the Mac books and we are surprised to
see how well the graphics on the 20/20
air performed again because of the new
graphics ship in the 10 gen Intel CPUs
also the 13
MacBook Pro scores went down since last
year which was really weird possibly due
to a new metal testing method in the
latest Geekbench 5 update and you can
see this when looking at graphics
performance per dollar the 6-inch Pro is
now the winner in terms of value for
graphics power but the new 20/20 air is
not too far behind and since the 16 inch
Pro has such a good graphics chip we
decided to test gaming performance using
Unigine 7 Xtreme preset and it
completely obliterated the rest of the
lineup with more than four times the
gaming performance of the $1,800.00 Pro
so if you want to do some gaming on the
side by the 16 inch Pro we also tested
the SSD speeds and here the $1300 Pro is
the loser because it's the only one that
comes with only 128 gigs of storage you
actually have to pay $1500 to get a
model with 256 gigs and for that reason
the air is actually quite a bit faster
in terms of writing speed even faster
than on the $1,800 13-inch Pro but the
16 inch pro wins because of its base 512
gigabyte SSD and in terms of read speeds
the $1,800.00 pro is quite a lot faster
with the 16 inch pro being the clear
winner so with all those performance
tests out of the way let's break down
which macbook you should buy for your
specific use case the 20/20 MacBook Air
with the quad-core CPU for $1100 is now
the best choice unless you're gonna use
it for a heavy tasks like video or photo
editing all of the time if you just do a
bit of productivity work the air might
not perform well for long term tasks but
it'll still get the job done and is
actually very snappy for light tasks the
major benefit is of course the lower
$1,100 price tag
while having double the storage as a
$1300 pro and the new updated magic
keyboard which is much more reliable
better yet we experienced about 20% more
battery life on the air compared to the
13-inch Pro now if you actually do a lot
of productivity work like video editing
the 13-inch pro is a great choice
because the cooling system is a lot
better and not only that but it packs a
brighter and more color accurate display
for things like photo editing the only
downside is that you have to
with the butterfly keyboard but of
course you can hold off until this
summer when we may potentially see the
release of a 13-inch MacBook Pro with
the magic keyboard now that $1,800
13-inch Pro is in a really tough spot
because it honestly isn't that much more
powerful than the $1300 Pro it just has
a few luxury improvements like an extra
two Thunderbolt three ports faster SSD
speeds the extra cooling fan and better
speakers I would honestly recommend
everyone to completely ignore the $1,800
Pro and buy the 16 inch pro instead
because of the newer design new features
like the magic keyboard the 512 gigabyte
base SSD and much more performance this
is definitely the MacBook Pro that I
would recommend people to buy if they
have the budget to spend on a MacBook
it's just better in so many ways and
it's currently on sale for 2287 on
Amazon so use the link below if you're
interested so there you have it if
you're still confused on which one to
buy comment down below and we'll help
you out and if you want to see more
videos on the new 20/20 MacBook Air
check out one of those two videos right
over there and click the circle a box to
subscribe thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]